All right guys, so here is another example of the market maker by model as you can see we took out the external liquidity right here
So now we have this fairly gap in the premium. So that is gonna be our draw on liquidity
So let's go to the five minute remember from one hour. We go to five minute, right?
Now we have taken out our objective. So let's identify
Consolidation phases so right here. We have one consolidation and that is gonna be our original consolidation right here, right?
Let's move this up like that
So we have consolidation here and consolidation here. These two lines are
Favourite gap. So that is gonna be our draw on liquidity. What do we have after taking out the objective which is external liquidity?
We have a market structure shift here
Now if you don't know if you're confused as to why is there some market structure shift go and watch my video on YouTube
Which says how to identify high probability market structure shifts, right?
Price didn't take out this high
But it did a break of structure instead of market structure shift now once you have a break double break of structure
After price takes out a key level that is a valid market structure shift if that makes sense
Just watch that video on YouTube. So we have this autoblock here consecutive bearish candles going long just right here
Right, we put our shop right below this autoblock and we target this level which is a draw on liquidity, right?
The consolidation phases tells us that we are in a market maker buy model, right? It gives us confidence. So playing this through
You can see that the take profit level was instantly hit and we took out this range
This consolidation high as well giving us 2.29 rr. So let's move on to the next example